[Musique]
un demi million de personnes regardent
le marathon de boston dans les rues de
la nouvelle angleterre à gérer que pas
de bêtises
subir plusieurs explosions à vous
on doit décider de qui s'occupe de cette
affaire et on doit décider de toute
urgence qui c'est du terrorisme c'est
pour vous à partir du moment où on parle
de terrorisme tout change s'est pas
blessé je vais bientôt me fais attention
à toi le type là la casquette blanche
c'est lui le foot au sud où on voit rien
non on voit très bien diffuser ces
photos et les gens vont en faire qu'une
bouchée
nous réclamons l'aide du public pour
réussir à identifier ces deux suspects
[Musique]
ont retrouvé ses enfants rêvent qu'ils
blessent d'autres personnes
entendu parler de la bombe au baratin
oui bien sûr si ça qui a fait ça n'ont
pas c'est moi une vaste chasse à l'homme
est lancée pour retrouver les suspects
chaque centimètre carré dans cette ville
pas être fouillée
catherine y at il d'autres bombes je
veux un avocat non
ah bon j'ai des droits
ce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui c'est le bien
contre le mal
contre la haye
peu de larmes pour les combattre
c'est l'amour il n'a aucune chance et
gagner
[Musique]